sometimes I just want to sit and be a
team but I can't do that because I'm
constantly thinking about how my life is
going to look like at 25 and the
decisions that I make now I use social
media but I don't think I'm addicted I
could take it or leave it
I can put my phone down whenever I want
that's a good skill I cannot do that I'm
I want my phone all the time like all
the time like I need to check Instagram
I need to check who's texting I need to
see like what's happening it's hard it
distracts me a lot from school so I
personally I use social media for a
total of I think two weeks after like
severe disappointment and saying that
social media could bring out the worst
in people I decided that I'm not gonna
use social media if I really need to
speak to someone and I could just text
them or call them or talk in person
yeah I was only recently allowed to get
so quote three months ago when I turn 18
because I wasn't allowed to have it up
until then like I have to make up for
all the time that I miss and everything
that happened and all the parties that I
didn't go to because I didn't see the
Instagram I'm not like on it all the
time but I'm definitely on my phone way
too much I think my screen times like
six hours or something crazy I know I
know it's bad
I think there's always gonna be things
that like own it pick at but overall I'm
pretty happy with the way that I look
and I know that the things that I can
control I'll change them and the things
that I can't control it would be a shame
for me to spend my life not enjoying my
physical appearance I respect myself
definitely but I feel like I'll never be
enough I don't know if that's part of me
struggling with my mental health but I'm
just not happy with the way I look but
I'm so proud of Who I am
[Music]
there's no way that I should be this
stressed like I feel like there's so
much pressure put on teens of what is
the future that I'm constantly like
chastising myself for things that I did
in the past or over analyzing everything
that I'm gonna do in the future and I
don't I literally don't know how to live
and like the now sometimes I just want
to sit and be a team but I can't do that
because I'm constantly thinking about
how my life is gonna look like at 25 and
the decisions that I make now I
personally I like the stress I'm always
thinking about the future and what I
want to do so if I want to do those
things in the future I have to
accomplish it a lot here you know I kind
of wish I didn't have it because I want
to do fun things instead of work
constantly for me my stress has affected
my mental and physical health which at
14 isn't something that should be
happening you know I shouldn't have
restless nights I shouldn't be drinking
coffee to stay awake
due to recent events it has crossed my
mind it is a reality for us as students
especially going to a public school but
I'm not gonna worry about it 24/7
because then I'm not living I'm not that
scared about because my school is really
small and I don't know the motivation
for someone to shoot up a school but if
you're really unhappy there you could
switch schools or just drop out I think
for us especially our school was like
pretty much on lockdown like all the
teachers are putting up like black paper
on their windows and that scared me more
than the natural threats just talk
doesn't really scare me but it's like if
the teachers start taking proactive
measures and at our school of them was
preparing for it and that's what freaks
me out I care about it because I think a
lot of things are happening are
irreversible but it is hard being in
school and being just a kid to make a
difference even the small things that we
think might not be affecting us are
eventually going to affect us if we do
nothing a lot of those times we live in
our own bubble especially because of our
phones and it's important to know what's
going around the world my family comes
from Nicaragua so that's why I learned
about it but I also learn about what's
happening in other countries because I
find it interesting and I would want
someone else to do the same for me as
well we might not know how or why but it
is going to affect us I disagree a
little bit with the whole in a bubble
because of our phones because I think
the internet and our phones in general
kind of are providing information and
sources to get to us faster than before
I agree with that I do but when I say
that we're living in a bubble how
many of us actually look up those
articles because most of us we just are
on Instagram what is happening anything
other than their dictator he took away
their health care and their social
security so they kind of revolted
against him and sometimes they just lock
you up or kill you there have been
almost 400 people dead and thousands
injured
that's horrible that should be a
headline like I usually just look at all
the headlines by I had no idea like I
I've literally never heard anyone talk
about that yeah we had a walkout a while
ago when all the shootings had happened
and one of the kids actually in the
grade below me organized that and
organized it through social media and
was like hey everyone we're gonna march
at City Hall like this is what we're
gonna do but I don't think that would
have been possible if it was all like
face-to-face contacts I think we're more
influential than we think because it's
all about our mindset and what we think
about our power that we have just in our
phones we can get millions of people a
message out to them that with all this
technology we definitely have more of a
voice than previous teenager generations
[Music]
it was a good name hey guys I'm Michael
and I'm Kendra thank you so much for
watching this episode of spectrum if you
liked it make sure to like the video
subscribe follow us on Instagram leave a
comment below and we'll see you next
time
[Music]